KRZYSZTOF GRYGIEL: Hi.
I'm Krzysztof from the
Google Cloud Autoscaler team.
In this tutorial,
I'm going to talk
about how to build scalable
applications on Google Compute
Engine using the Compute Engine
autoscaling and load balancing
services.
The load balancing service
lets you distribute traffic
across many virtual machines,
while the autoscaling
service ensures that
there are always
enough virtual machines
to handle an increase
or decrease in load.
By the end of this
video, you will
know how to create
a simple scalable
service using both autoscaling
and load balancing.
First, we'll set the stage
and discuss a scenario
where a user requires to scale
the application front end.
Then, we'll go over
how Compute Engine can
address some of these needs.
Finally, we will run
some actual examples.
Now let's get started.
Imagine you're a
developer who has just
built a new web application,
and you're about to launch it.
Let's assume that your
application consists
of the following components.
A front end web server with an
external IP address associated
with your service; a
back end server handling
all of the business
logic and computation
for the application; and
a persistent storage,
such as a MySQL database,
where you will store
all permanent application data.
So we have your serving
infrastructure running,
and are now receiving
requests from your users.
As the user base and traffic
to your application grows,
your front end running
on a single instance
will soon reach
its capacity limit
and won't have enough
CPU power to process
more parallel requests
coming from your users.
However, since the front
end of your application
is a stateless server,
it can be replicated
to multiple virtual
machines to handle
many simultaneous requests.
Knowing this can help
address potential
serving capacity problems.
If you provision more
front end instances
and hook it up to
your back end system,
you can serve more
requests in parallel.
Of course, the back
end instance could
be scaled in a similar
way, as long as it is also
a stateless server.
That is, if all persistent state
lives only in the database.
We now have more capacity, and
no request should be dropped.
There is one issue, however.
Right now, you have
multiple front end servers,
each with a distinct IP address.
So you have enough capacity
to serve the user traffic,
but you need a way to distribute
it across these servers.
What you need is a single IP
address for all your users
to connect to.
To do this, you can set up a
network load balancer, which
exposes a single
external IP to the world
and forwards the traffic across
multiple front end instances,
ensuring your instances
experience uniform load.
As the traffic to your
service increases,
you would keep adding
front end servers
so that the serving
capacity can always
handle the observed traffic.
While this process might
work well in the beginning,
you might begin to notice that
the volume of incoming traffic
varies depending
on time of the day.
You'll also notice
that on some days,
you have more traffic
than other days.
While you keep
adding machines to be
able to serve the maximum
number of user connections,
you quickly realize
that you also
want to remove servers during
periods of low traffic.
So, in fact, your serving needs
to look roughly like this.
And you could save money
overall if you added and removed
servers in response
to changes in traffic,
rather than maintaining the
maximum number of servers
all the time.
Here is where an autoscaler
can come to the rescue.
Instead of keeping
track of traffic
and adjusting the number
of servers manually,
you could configure autoscaler
to do the job for you
automatically.
An autoscaler
constantly keeps track
of how busy a group of instances
are by watching the utilization
level of instances.
You define what utilization
metric the autoscaler watches,
such as average CPU
load, and define
a specific per-instance
utilization target,
and the autoscaler automatically
works to maintain this target.
For example, you might
the set the utilization
target of your instances
at 60% CPU utilization.
When the CPU utilization
exceeds this target,
the autoscaler
adds more instances
to handle the load
automatically.
Let's assume you have
one instance receiving
one request per second,
which consumes 30% of the CPU
on the machine.
If the traffic suddenly grows
to three requests per second,
the machine will run
hot, using 90% of CPU.
At this point, the autoscaler
will add as many instances
as necessary to get it below
the target utilization, which
in our example is just
one extra instance.
With two instances,
the load drops
to 1.5 requests per
second per instance,
and the CPU utilization drops
to 45% on each instance, which
is below the target 60%
utilization that we defined
earlier.
If the utilization remains
low for a long time
and it is possible
to keep utilization
below the target with a
fewer number of instances,
autoscaler will start
removing instances.
Now that we have
defined our scenario,
let's go over the
configuration steps
you would need to
set up your resources
like we just described.
First, you need a
group of instances.
To create it, you must
define an instance template
which describes the image,
machine type, startup script,
and other properties of the
virtual machines in the group.
This template will be used
to create new instances
in the future, as well, either
by the autoscaling service,
or if you manually add a
new instance to the group.
Then, create your
group of instances.
Use the instance
template from step one
to create a managed
instance group which
contains any number of
identical instances.
Once you have created the
managed instance group,
you can enable
autoscaling for the group.
Finally, create the network
load balancer to handle traffic
from a single external IP.
The network load balancer
talks to a group of back ends
called the target pool.
A target pool can contain
individual instances or groups
of instances.
In this case, it would just
consist of the single managed
instance group you create.
The network load balancer
uses a forwarding rule
which defines the protocol,
IP address, and port
the users will talk to.
That's it.
Now it's time to try
it out in practice.
We are going to use
the developer's console
to perform all the steps.
We assume that you already
have a Google Cloud Platform
project set up.
For the purpose of
this demonstration,
we'll only create
the front end layer,
which will respond
to HTTP requests
without talking to a back end.
Step one, create an
instance template.
Go to Instance Templates
pane, and choose New Instance
Template.
At this step, you are selecting
machine type, operating system,
and disk for your servers.
Use the default settings.
Give a name to your template,
and check Allow HTTP Traffic.
Finally, add a startup
script for your VM
in the Instance Metadata field.
For this example, we are
adding a startup script
that downloads the
front end application
code from cloud storage.
The front end is a super simple
web server written in Python
which only simulates the effect
of real request processing
by running an idle loop
that consumes some CPU
power in response to
HTTP get requests.
In a real application, we
would replace this idle loop
with some logic to do request
processing, communication
with the back end, and to
generate HTTP responses.
The code for this demo
is available under
storage.googleap
is.com/autoscale
r-demo/frontend.py.
Based on the code, notice
that our front end will serve
requests under
the path /service.
So we will later be
appending it to the HTTP
address of the front end.
Of course, if you prefer,
instead of using the Python
app, you could install a
standard Apache web server
and try the PHP script
for a similar result.
Step two, create
an instance group
using the template that you just
defined, and enable autoscaler.
Select a preferred
zone for your service
to operate, and give
your group a name.
The autoscaler configuration
is pre-filled with defaults.
Here we will use the average
CPU utilization of the VMs
as the utilization
metric to measure.
The target utilization
is set to 60%.
Also keep in mind that
the autoscaling policy
can be customized.
Instead of CPU usage, you
could choose other utilization
metrics, such as rate of
requests going through the load
balancer, or arbitrary
cloud monitoring metrics.
For now, we'll just
use the defaults.
Click Create to create
your instance group.
Creating the instance group
may take about two minutes.
Check when the group
is ready by watching
the Activities tab in the bottom
right corner of the screen.
To see the details of
the instance group,
select it in the
Instance Groups pane.
Here we can see that the first
instance has been created.
Step three, configure
load balancer.
Select Network Load Balancing.
You may notice that there
is another option called
HTTP Load Balancing next to it.
This is a more advanced form
of load balancing, which
offers options specific to
HTTP traffic such as balancing
based on URL map.
As we don't need these
advanced features,
we are going to use the
generic network load
balancing for this example.
Go to the Basic Setup tab of
the Network Load Balancing page.
Under Region, choose
the same region
where the instance group lives.
The forwarding rule section
specifies the endpoint
that your users will
send the traffic to.
Leave it set to the
default options.
That this, ephemeral IP,
port number 80, TCP traffic.
Then we define the target pool.
Recall that the target pool
is the group of instances
that the network load balancer
will forward traffic to.
We choose Select
Existing Instance Group,
and pick the instance group we
created in the previous step.
That's it.
You're done setting
up your configuration.
You can test your stack
by entering the IP address
of the forwarding rule
in the web browser,
followed by the /service path.
To get the external IP address
of the forwarding rule,
go to the Forwarding Rules
tab of the same menu.
It works.
So far, the load balancer
didn't have to do much work,
since the front end
only had one instance.
For a real test, send some
more traffic to the instance.
Let's run a shell script to
send HTTP get requests to the IP
address of the forwarding rule.
This command generates one
HTTP request every second.
The front end was implemented to
consume one second of CPU time
to serve a single request.
So on a single core
machine, it will
be running at 100% utilization.
The autoscaler should
start another instance soon
to handle the increase in load.
Let's return to the
Instance Group page
and select our instance group.
Here we go.
The Instance Group page now
shows an additional instance
added by the autoscaler.
Let's try to double their load.
Simply decrease the delay
between the requests
to half a second.
We should see the response
time immediately going up.
Some requests are
even timing out.
In a short while, autoscaler
adds another two instances.
The response time
drops down to normal.
I encourage you to experiment
more with this setup.
You may notice that
when the traffic stops,
it takes a while before
the autoscaler starts
deleting the instances.
This is to reduce
disruption to the service,
and to avoid the cost
of frequent restarts
of virtual machines.
We hope that this presentation
demonstrated how easily you
can start building your
own scalable applications
with Google Cloud Platform.
Autoscaler is designed to work
equally well for Google scale
applications, running on
hundreds of virtual machines,
to let you take full advantage
of the Google Cloud Platform
scale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]